those Airline troubles have been ongoing
for nearly a week now thousands say they
were stranded but some of them finally
making it home Ryan Matthey joining us
now live from Reed International just
outside what is a growing number of
unclaimed Southwest bags Ryan
yeah Denise Vanessa there are still
thousands of unclaimed bags here and the
current number still sits at about 3 000
bags and that's specifically for
Southwest customers amongst this sea
right here potentially sits some from
the Roberson family they're one of the
few who have now made it home but the
journey back was anything but a
Christmas miracle
I actually have probably a wallet here
of all the tickets that they rescheduled
us for Jessica Robertson her fiance
four-year-old and seven month old had a
Southwest flight out of Las Vegas
Christmas Eve morning destination
Cleveland I probably spent 10 hours 11
hours in the airport they're also in the
midst of moving closer to family in Ohio
but flight after flight delayed canceled
rebooked then canceled again keeping
them in Las Vegas when she tried to get
her checked bags back which included
medications for her ovarian cancer
diagnosis they got on a PA system and
said we are not getting you your bags
off the plane we will not be getting
your car seats off the plane forcing
hundreds of dollars in Uber fares back
and forth between their old apartments
with no car seats until a Monday flight
to Chicago their connecting flight to
Cleveland canceled so they rented a car
that's when we found out that the spare
had been used recently because it was
still covered in snow one of the wheels
began against smoking on the side of an
Indiana Turnpike roadside assistance
never showing up all in snow next to
speeding traffic before a State Trooper
helped so I'm wearing my winter coat
with you because it's literally the only
clothing that I have they're now at
their new home three days later but
their belongings still in Las Vegas when
we ask when they think they'll get them
here the answer is we don't know when
they get here we'll let you know we'll
deliver them the extra days costing them
an estimated three thousand dollars more
pushing back her son's baptism in
Christmas plans with family and I had to
explain to my four-year-old that Santa
was basically overbooked and would be
there in a couple days what happened was
more than just postponing people's
Christmas it took way more than that
from people and I don't think they
understand that
now compensating Flyers with experience
like hers is confusing enough now
Robertson says she was unfairly
compensated for the extra fees that she
paid and she has since hired a lawyer to
address that as those internal Airline
conflicts continue to come to light
reporting live from Harry Reid
International Ryan Matthey a news now